[Musique]
la première ils sont pas là pour toi
seul avait donc bien propre douche ou un
bain avant la beauté c'est pas important
ce qui compte c'est d'être propre ne
surtout pas porter un regard sur ce
qu'on est en train de faire et tous les
copains qui disent du mal de vous
derrière l'écran chez eux
l'horloge continuer à distraire les
spectateurs se dans la salle et ceux de
l'autre côté de l'écran c'est à dire
trouver un langage qui soit léger
divertissant amusant mais tout qu'est ce
qui vient après il reste quand même
temps est-ce que j'ai eue de la salade
entre les dents la deuxième chose il ya
comme un taux de change
un petit rire du public des césar ça
équivaut un gros éclat de rire à
l'olympia et un standing-ovation au
zénith d'amiens
c'est pas que t'es pas drôle c'est juste
que c'est comme ça d'être sympathique
peut-être le sourire quand ça va pas
s'amuser le tempo général essayez de
retendre le fils quand il s'est un peu
détendue de savoir s'éclipser si on me
donnait le choix entre faire une
présentation de cérémonie sar y est à
toutes mes vannes ou alors recevoir un
césar
je dirais les deux et masquent pas
montré quand on est déçu et mon pote qui
te donner peut pas tu peux pas quand
maîtres de cérémonie que c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui montre récupérer son césar
et que ton pote est pas monté regarder
ton pote depuis la guerre et la
troisième
boire un p'tit coup parce que sinon dans
la bouche pâteuse être le trac
où est-ce qu'ils ont rigolé et a pas
trois choses il ya mille choses qui se
passent à prendre position c'est avoir
une bonne résistance parce que c'est
long pour tout donner à l'entrée parce
que sinon on a une grosse surprise aux
deux tiers à laquelle sera conseille
donc lantoine
[Musique]
lancel a pas besoin de moi avec toi
florence évidemment qu'il ya un nuage
d'amour qui entourent florence foresti
et qu'il apporte
jusqu en influence ça c'est capital
quand cl il ya du swing quoi quand cm ça
c'est génial
elle a un regard extrêmement tendre et
moderne sur les choses et c'est pour ça
qu'elle est elle est numéro 1 et en même
temps ça peut aussi se passer moyens si
j'étais là dans dans son épaule jeu-là
déconcentre recht des conneries toytoy
comme on dit merde bâché rivasi
je suis derrière toi et on n'est pas là
voilà on peut pas tout réussir et bon
courage donc la seule chose que j'ai à
dire à florence c'est d'être elle parce
que c'est là qu'elle est incroyable
formidable drôle et qu'elle nous éclate
vraiment juste des plats soient
personnellement si tu te déplaces
personnellement ça va ça va être super
[Musique]
c'est la meilleure flou tu veux battre
planté